L'utilisation des sous-produits
de l'huile de palme dans la
ration des vaches a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre cet hiver.
Plusieurs ont été étonnés
d'apprendre que cet aliment
controversé, associé notamment
à la déforestation en Asie
du Sud-Est, était donné
à des vaches laitières ici.
Deux mois après que les
Producteurs laitiers du Canada
aient demandé à leurs membres
d'envisager, de manière
volontaire, des alternatives
à ces suppléments, nous faisons
le point sur la situation.
♪ ♪ ♪
La ferme Wittekind, à Delta,
dans l'est de l'Ontario. Elle
a été fondée par le père d'Éric
Baumann, arrivé d'Allemagne en
1982. Aujourd'hui, elle compte
40 vaches Jerseys en lactation.
Éric Baumann nous montre
ce que mange son troupeau.
- Ici, tu as la ration finale
pour la vache. Alors là,
c'est tout mélangé.
Et dans la main gauche ici,
on a l'acide palmitique; c'est
déjà dans la ration finale.
- Chaque jour, une Jersey mange
20 kilos de matière sèche,
principalement de l'ensilage
de maïs, de soya et de foin.
Et depuis quatre ans, Éric
Baumann ajoute une petite
quantité d'acide palmitique
à la ration.
- Ici, on donne 100 grammes
par jour par vache.
C'est pas beaucoup.
- Ça correspond à 0,5 %
de ce qu'elle mange.
- C'est pas une source primaire
de la ration, c'est juste
quelque chose pour aider
leur performance.
- Éric Baumann est étudiant au
doctorat en nutrition animale.
C'est lors d'un projet de
recherche qu'il constate
l'impact des suppléments
d'huile de palme sur les vaches.
- Ici, pour nous, je trouve que
ça augmente la teneur de gras
par environ 0,1 %.
- Ces produits ne sont pas bon
marché, mais ils sont rentables.
À la ferme Wittekind, chaque
dollar investi en suppléments
d'acide palmitique en rapportera
trois, ce qui se traduit par
quelques milliers de dollars
de plus à la fin de l'année.
- Le taux de gras dans le lait,
c'est important, premièrement,
parce qu'on est payé pour le
gras. Et si on a un supplément
qui va monter la teneur de gras
de la vache, les mêmes vaches
peuvent livrer plus de kilos
de gras laitier par jour;
c'est-à-dire qu'on rend
les vaches plus efficaces.
- Et tant que ce produit sera
approuvé par Santé Canada,
comme c'est toujours le cas,
Éric Baumann n'a pas l'intention
d'arrêter d'en donner.
- Je suis producteur, mais aussi
je suis consommateur. Nous, dans
ma famille, on boit notre lait
à chaque jour. Je ne vais pas
mettre quelque chose dans la
ration de mes vaches où je suis
pas certain que c'est bon pour
les vaches ou pour les humains.
- La nouvelle tartinade
aux noisettes de Kraft est
faite sans huile de palme.
- Sauf que c'est un produit avec
lequel plusieurs prennent leurs
distances. Sa production est
synonyme de déforestation et
de destruction d'habitats pour
plusieurs espèces menacées,
sans compter le fait que
plus d'un million d'enfants
travaillent dans les palmeraies
en Asie du Sud-Est.
Utilisée dans les aliments
transformés, les cosmétiques,
les biocarburants, la peinture,
l'huile de palme a vu sa
production mondiale multipliée
par cinq depuis 1995. Au Canada,
depuis 2007, les importations
d'huile de palme ont augmenté de
400 %. Cette immense popularité
s'explique entre autres par
les rendements exceptionnels
de cette culture. Pour produire
la même quantité d'huile de
soya, de tournesol ou de canola,
il faudrait jusqu'à neuf fois
plus de terres.
Opter pour une autre huile
aurait aussi des conséquences
sur l'environnement.
Mais pourrait-on même remplacer
l'huile de palme, très digeste
pour la vache, par une huile
produite localement? Pas si
simple, selon cette spécialiste
de la nutrition animale.
- Ce serait une façon, par
exemple, de donner de l'huile de
tournesol, de donner de l'huile
de maïs, d'enrichir la densité
énergétique de la ration
de l'animal. Par contre,
le rumen va en souffrir.
- Elle nous explique que deux
raisons motivent l'ajout de
suppléments d'huile de palme :
pour augmenter le taux de gras
tout au long de la lactation,
comme chez Éric Baumann, et pour
aider la vache, particulièrement
en début de lactation.
- Il faut comprendre que ces
animaux-là passent d'un état
où ils produisent pas de lait;
quelques semaines plus tard,
ils vont produire 50 kilos de
lait, qui contient à peu près
4 %, même plus que 4 % de gras.
- 50 kilos équivalent
grosso modo à 50 litres.
- Ça, c'est par jour.
Donc c'est énormément d'énergie.
Il faut augmenter la densité
énergétique de la ration de
notre animal, puis on est limité
par les ingrédients qu'on peut
utiliser. Donc là, une bonne
façon d'augmenter l'énergie,
c'est de... puis c'est vrai
pour les humains aussi,
c'est de donner des lipides.
- Si on a aujourd'hui recours
aux suppléments de gras comme
l'huile de palme, c'est entre
autres parce qu'au fil du temps,
on a sélectionné les vaches pour
qu'elles soient toujours plus
productives. Pour nourrir son
petit, une vache n'a besoin que
de 8 litres de lait par jour,
alors qu'en production laitière
elle peut en livrer plus de 60.
- Au début de la lactation,
l'animal a des besoins
énergétiques qui surpassent
sa capacité d'ingestion,
donc il faut augmenter
la densité énergétique.
- En d'autres mots, la vache
n'a pas assez de place dans
ses estomacs pour contenir toute
la nourriture nécessaire à une
production intensive de lait.
Il faut donc ajouter des
suppléments riches en énergie.
- Souvent, je m'amuse à
les comparer à des athlètes
olympiques de haut niveau.
On nourrit pas un athlète
olympique avec de la salade!
Ça fait que c'est des animaux
qui ont des grands, grands
besoins énergétiques.
- Et comme les athlètes
olympiques, leur carrière est
courte. Au Canada, à peine
la moitié des vaches survivent
à leur troisième vêlage,
alors qu'elles auraient le
potentiel de vivre beaucoup plus
longtemps. En 2018, un sondage
des Producteurs de lait du
Québec révélait que 22 % d'entre
eux utilisaient des suppléments
d'huile de palme. En Ontario et
dans les provinces de l'Ouest,
cette proportion serait de 55 %.
La pratique a cours depuis des
décennies dans le monde laitier,
mais ce n'est que cet hiver
que le grand public en a pris
connaissance. Alors que les gens
sont confinés à la maison et
cuisinent plus qu'à l'habitude,
certains remarquent que le
beurre serait peut-être plus
dur qu'avant. Les suppléments
d'acide palmitique sont
soudainement montrés du doigt.
♪ ♪ ♪
À l'Université Guelph, le
chercheur Alejandro Marangoni a
analysé 50 marques différentes
de beurre. Il constate une
corrélation : plus le beurre
contient de l'acide palmitique,
un acide gras qui est solide
à la température de la pièce,
plus il est dur.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
L'huile de palme est sans danger
pour les vaches. Elle fournit
l'énergie dont elles ont besoin
pour l'énorme quantité de lait
produite quotidiennement.
- Le lait d'une vache qui
ne mange que du fourrage
contiendra quand même de l'acide
palmitique. C'est naturel.
Mais si on ajoute des
suppléments à la ration,
il en contiendra plus.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Ce qui se passe, et la
littérature scientifique
l'avait déjà décrit, c'est
qu'en ajoutant des suppléments
à la ration des animaux, le
beurre est plus riche en acide
palmitique et aussi plus dur.
- Si ses analyses donnent un
aperçu de la situation actuelle
pour le beurre, le professeur
Marangoni ne peut pas conclure
que les vaches mangent plus
d'acide palmitique qu'avant,
parce qu'il n'existe aucune
donnée historique. D'autres
facteurs, comme des changements
de procédés en usine pourraient
aussi influencer la dureté
du beurre.
Les producteurs de lait tiennent
à le préciser : ce qu'ils
utilisent, c'est un résidu
de l'extraction de l'huile de
palme. Chez Éric Baumann, il est
certifié de source durable.
- Je pense c'est une question
plus globale. Il y a toujours
une demande pour les produits
moins chers. La demande pour
l'huile de palme, c'est pas là à
cause des producteurs laitiers.
Ça vient du consommateur qui
veut l'huile de palme dans ses
granola bars, dans ses biscuits,
dans le savon, dans les
cosmétiques.
- Aujourd'hui, on estime que
près 50 % des aliments emballés
contiendraient de l'huile de
palme.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Veut-on réellement de toute
cette nourriture bon marché,
produite à n'importe quel prix?
L'huile de palme en est un
excellent exemple. C'est l'huile
la moins chère sur la planète,
produite au détriment des forêts
vierges et des animaux. Mais
sommes-nous prêts à payer plus?
- En fait, ces produits-là,
est-ce qu'ils sont
indispensables? Certainement pas
puisque que c'est pas tous les
producteurs qui l'utilisent,
puis les vaches réussissent
quand même à très bien
performer.
(cloches à vache)
- Et le pays qui en a fait
la preuve, c'est la Suisse.
- En 2017, un reportage à la
télé suisse allemande révèle la
présence de suppléments d'huile
de palme dans la ration des
vaches. Le public est choqué.
Un an plus tard, les producteurs
suisses abandonnent les
sous-produits d'huile de palme.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'utilisation d'une huile,
produite à des milliers de
kilomètres, dans des conditions
qui ne correspondent pas
toujours à nos valeurs,
soulève de vastes questions.
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Est-ce qu'on souhaite une
efficacité maximale à moindre
coût et des volumes toujours
plus grands? Ou on commence
à prendre en considération
les pratiques durables et
la santé animale dans la
production alimentaire?
- (traduit de l'anglais):
Je ne veux pas montrer du doigt
les consommateurs, parce que
c'est notre affaire à tous.
Le sujet est complexe et si les
impacts de la production d'huile
de palme sur les forêts et
la faune nous inquiètent,
il faut y travailler ensemble.
Si on commence par bannir
l'utilisation d'un sous-produit,
on ne s'attaque pas au vrai
problème.